We've helped you focus on you, and
the message that you convey
into your professional network.
But what about actually
building a LinkedIn network?
This is where all of your hard
work comes into fruition.
It's time to get connected with others.
Why connect?
Networking is important.
Having a connection can actually be
even more powerful than your skills or
expertise once you have a network, you
might be able to find a connection at
a company you want to work for, and more
people will be aware of your job hunt.
Who should you connect with?
Connect with people who like you and
who know how you work.
Don't connect with someone you've never
met and found via search on LinkedIn and
don't be spamming.
The connections section can also be
a great place for recommendations.
But be selective on who you
asked to recommend you.
Reach out to people who are intimately
aware of the work you've done and
who can speak specifically
about how you contributed.
But don't call for too many.
One recommendation per major
work experience is fine.
If you have five recommendations for
one job, it can look like you
are twisting their arms to write them.